There's a place for you here,
both of you. Counting on it.
Adios, big brother.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
This'll be my Full
Last of Us Episode 6 Video
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
in references.
We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
carefully for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll start at the beginning, work
our way through, shop by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode titled Kin.
It was a reference
to Joel reuniting with his brother
Tommy at a settlement in Wyoming.
It's also a reference
to John Ellis relationship
because by the end of the episode
they start to think of each other
more as kin.
Not completely, but they're much closer.
The opening scene actually replays
the events of the end of episode five,
with Henry killing his younger
brother Sam, who'd been infected
and then killing himself in despair.
And there's a three month time jump
which is similar to the games.
There was a time jump after they left
Henry and Sam.
The season was a little bit different.
There wasn't snow on the ground
when they made it to Tommy's.
I think they changed that, so
it just feels like a lot more
time has passed in the cover.
A bunch of plot.
By the time
Joel gets wounded at the university
at the end of the episode in the game,
it takes a little bit longer
to get to that point.
And when Ellie was forced to protect him,
like while he's bleeding out there
trying to survive, it became winter.
Like more time
passed was another time jump.
So it just seems like
they want that to happen
a little bit quicker in the episodes.
I'm not expecting a giant time
jump for episode seven.
There might be a small time jump though.
Joel and Ellie have made it
much further west, closer
to where Tommy Settlement is in Wyoming.
They try to get help from the older
couple living in the remote shack
outside of Cody. That's here.
Tommy's settlement is a little ways away,
but they did add a lot
in this episode, and part of the episode
is very different from the game.
Some of the scenes are very close
to the game, though, and there's Jack.
You see the man strung up a deer carcass.
They just been living a quiet life.
They're away from all the craziness,
the fungus, the infected, his rabbit
he's caught. There might be an Easter egg
for the rabbits meme.
Someone uploaded a clip
a long time ago reacting to a rabbit
being shot in the last of us freaking out.
It went viral.
Then Naughty Dog
actually added as a secret reference
in the last of Us to game
when they published it,
the couple explains
They just got really lucky in 2003
because they'd moved out there long before
that just to be away from people.
And that's probably one of the smartest
things that they could have done.
Even though the wife says
she didn't want anything to do with it.
Like I didn't want to move out here,
but my husband did.
You said earlier you don't really find
infected in remote areas like this
as much.
They tend to group around populated areas
because it's their main food source
allowing the fungus to grow and spread.
When he says
never go past this area around the river,
they only ever find dead bodies of those
who tried to enter that area.
It's meant to be Tommy's group
who just kill either infected people
trying to get into their settlement or
dangerous people like raiders in general.
The vibe that you get from Tommy's
settlement is pretty authentic.
Like they're meant
to be a good group of people.
But there are bands of raiders
and cannibals all over the place
who are way more dangerous
than the fungus.
As Joel and Ellie find at the end of the
episode, when Joel starts freaking out,
the moment they leave,
he's having a panic attack
because he's so worried about his brother
and what's happening with Ellie.
Like the fear inside him
is starting to manifest physically.
That's why he's having nightmares.
That's why he keeps having panic attacks
later in the episode.
It is that up to this point, he's
been very good at hiding his fear.
Ellie also reveals that he's been
mumbling in his sleep for a while now.
So it has been happening for a while.
It just it hasn't gone to full blown
panic attacks in daylight yet.
She tries to help him emotionally
a little bit here.
And later in the episode,
she literally has to help him.
It's a good example of how they depend
on each other, like she depends on him
to protect her, but
he is also depending on her to protect him
sometimes more emotionally
than physically.
At the end of the episode.
It's more physical though,
like Please protect me from bleeding out
in other raiders coming to kill us
as they continue on foot,
a montage plays them walking
across the landscape to the river.
The Last of Us
theme music starts playing again.
Ellie with the Rapids
is also foreshadowing for her learning
how to hunt in, having to hunt for the
both of them while he's in capacitated.
At the end of the episode,
love the moment of him sharing the booze
with her, a moment in every child's life
when their dad shares
a swig of beer or booze.
I had that moment too.
I think it was beer.
Probably about 11 years old.
Totally tasted gross to me at the time.
What kind of battery
acid are useful in here?
They references later
when he's drinking with Tommy in the bar.
But in the apocalypse, booze
would actually be one of the few things.
It's pretty simple to make moonshine,
basically homemade booze.
People do it all the time in real life
right now, even though in a lot of places
it's technically illegal, Ellie
starts to question what's next for them.
If they're successful
in finding a cure for the fungus, it's
a sign that she feels much closer to Joel
because in her head
she's wondering what's going to happen
to the two of them as a pair.
Is Joel going to take off
and leave her alone again?
She's worried about that.
While Joel, during the episode, admits
that he's worried about letting her down,
she's worried that he's
going to leave her alone again,
which is basically been happening
to her entire life.
Everyone she's ever known
has either died or left her
is one of those conversations
where she's kind of phishing
to try and find out what the future
of their relationship is like.
Like where is this headed right now?
She's still a job to him,
but his opinion of her is slowly changing.
Let me share those funny moments together.
Like you
get a little bit of dad vibes from him,
but it doesn't really care about her
that much yet.
At least he's not willing to admit it yet.
But you do see that his time with her
has started to make him a better person
because the way he talks about his past
with Tommy
when they were with the hunters,
he sounds like he did
a lot of really terrible stuff.
And he's being totally honest here
when he says that this is like
the first time that he's actually thought
about having a future.
He's never done it before because life
after the fungus for him in the apocalypse
has been a day to day exercise in basic
survival, at least up to this point,
making it to the next day.
And that's about it, which really isn't
a lot like it's barely existing.
But you kind of get that from Tommy.
Like Tommy finds this new life
and he wants Joel to join it.
Like,
we could actually have a really good life
here and leads
up to the end of the episode.
Joel just isn't ready to deal with that.
He jokes with her about the ship
setting up the joke later
in the episode where they find sheep
in a pen in the community.
It's also another example
of his sense of humor,
joking with her about being so talkative.
At least up to this point, though,
she tends to talk more, the more nervous,
more afraid she gets,
which is why she talks so much.
She says her wishes to travel to the moon
because her whole life
has been spent living in a cage,
so to speak, in the quarantine zones.
And leaving
Earth would represent, like the freest,
the furthest
you could possibly be from that cage.
Sally Ride, her hero, was the youngest
female astronaut in American history.
She was 32 at the time back in the 1980s.
Their kids in real life today
that are younger than that train to be
NASA astronauts in the absolute record
for youngest female in space
is actually held by a Russian woman
who was 24 back in the 1960s.
She confesses to trying to cure
Sam with her blood
and the fact that it didn't work
as a huge blow to her optimism
in the face of all this bleakness,
this whole mission,
she genuinely thought that it would work
for a hot second The next morning.
Ellie patrolling with George Gun
is foreshadowing for episode seven
because she's going to be doing that a lot
now while Jill's recovering
is also a good example of how
she's learned to survive on her own,
like she's not completely there,
but she has learned a lot of basic skills.
Then they arrive at the dam,
which is right out of the games,
but they change this interaction
that he has with Tommy in the games.
He actually met Tommy at the dam itself
while they were busy fixing it up.
And Maria as well.
They're all right.
But no, these people know him
as my goddamn brother, Tommy.
Oh, shit.
How you doing? My brother got down.
Yeah, I mean, look at you here.
They're taken by a group back
to their settlement.
Joel makes another, well, Livingston joke,
which is the person that wrote Ellie's
book of puns
that she kept reading from earlier.
No pun intended to.
The whole thing with the dam
is that Tommy's group fixed it
so they could use the power
for their community nearby.
When Ellie says
that she'd believe anything
that Joel said, even if he made up a lie,
it's also foreshadowing for big moments.
Later, he will tell her a very big lie.
When we meet Tommy's group.
You see, Rutina Wesley,
you probably recognize from True Blood.
She's playing Maria,
Tommy's new wife from the game.
The reason why the fungus detecting dog
doesn't detect the fungus in Ellie
because she is infected.
Is she just immune?
So there is some fungus inside her
is because the strain of fungus inside her
is a slightly different version.
That's good.
That's preventing the other bad fungus
from taking over her body
is how her immunity works.
So theoretically,
to create a vaccine from her, everyone on
the planet would have to get
that good type of fungus inside them.
It's kind of how basic vaccines work, too.
Like you give someone
a small dosage of the virus,
their body builds a natural immunity
to it, then you become immune.
Itches that Joel doesn't know anything
about that right now.
Like he clearly does not understand
how this all works, which is why
he almost craps his pants
when the dog starts smelling her.
As he explains to Tommy later.
The reason Maria recognizes him
is because Tommy told her about him.
And this whole part
where they take them into the settlement
is a big change from the games.
They do go there eventually,
but Tommy just shows in the settlement
and talks about it.
They don't actually go in there
until much, much later in the games.
You notice
the banner on the street reads 2003
because that's when the fungus spread.
The apocalypse started in culture,
kind of frozen time.
We get that great reunion scene
with Tommy and Joel.
It's one of the very few times in the show
where you see
Joel express emotions visibly.
But this episode was kind of like the dam
holding back all of his emotions,
breaking in like a long, dark
night of the salt.
Like he just bares everything to Tommy.
Later in the episode, going from showing
0% emotion to 100% on a dime.
The only other times you've really seen
Joel get super emotional on the show
is when his daughter died in 2003
and then again
when he knew the test was going to die
and they had to leave her behind.
They have a couple of funny moments
with Ellie
trying to socialize like a regular person
when others get curious about her.
She's used to living in a very kill
or be killed mode the whole time.
Just trying to survive.
Life in Tommy's town is as close
as you can get to a normal life or what?
It could be normal in the apocalypse.
So it's going to take a little while
for her to adjust.
They have movie nights, dances, musical
performances, all the normal things
you would do for entertainment.
It's meant to be perfect or as perfect
as you could get in the apocalypse
in a lot of the episode.
Is Joel thinking about what Ellie said,
given
what he learns about Tommy's new life
here?
Like,
Wait a minute, could I have a life here?
Should I have a life here?
Do I want to have a life here?
It takes until the end of the episode,
but he eventually decides, yes,
I will return here after our mission
to try and find the fireflies is over.
We find out the rest of what happened to
Tommy after he met up with Marlene
in sort of working with the fireflies.
Even though they're meant
to be a good faction,
they do a lot of violent stuff.
Their main goal is to overthrow Phaedra,
install a civilian government.
Kind of like
the one you see in Tommy's town here.
It also create a vaccine
to save the human race.
But in pursuit of those goals,
they do very terrible things.
So it sounds like Tommy grew disillusioned
with that, and that's when he left.
And he says that Maria's group found him
and he helped them
build this community here,
which they'd already been
in the process of building.
They're meant to be
completely self-contained.
They're not associated with the fireflies,
with any of the other factions
with Phaedra, which is why she says
that they don't have any contact
with the other groups.
And it's
why during the events of episode one,
Joel had lost contact
with Tommy for the past three weeks
because that's close to the time
when he moved into the settlement.
When Maria says having a bad reputation
doesn't mean you're bad, Always.
That's meant to be a metaphor
for Joel's character.
Like his reaction is in remembering
all the terrible things
that he's done to survive
when he was with the Hunters and Tommy,
which they also talk about later,
Tommy revealing that they're married
and they're going to have a child,
is also right out of the games, too.
It just happened
back at the dam in the games. Maria
Be nice to her.
She sort of runs things around here.
Ma'am,
Thanks for not blow my head off.
Would have been embarrassing,
considering you're my brother
in law.
We all got to get wrangled up
at some point.
Pretty much all the conversations
between Maria and Joel,
like all these heart to hearts
that they have, are similar in the games.
But they all happened back at the dam.
I'm guessing they make the communism
joke on Tommy
just because he was in the military.
It sounds like he fought some communists,
even though
when Tommy was back in the military,
there were only a couple
of Communist nations around the world.
There aren't so much world
governments now.
They're just versions of federal,
like in the United States,
in other nations, like other nations,
versions of what they're doing
in the United States.
Joel and Tommy
have it out over some homemade booze.
They had a version
of this conversation in the game,
but also happened back at the dam.
It goes about the same way in the game.
Tommy gives him the same information
about where they might find the fireflies
at their base
at the University of Colorado.
He lies about what happened to test
at this point, but eventually, later
in the episode when he bears his soul
to Tommy, all of his fears are he comes
clean about everything.
Then he admits
what really happened to her.
They argue over the morality
of what they've done to survive.
Tommy reveals he's going to be a father.
He has a greater responsible party
to his new family,
like the title of the episode is Kin.
Another metaphor to that, to a new family
that he started here in the settlement.
And when he starts talking about thinking
that he would be a good dad, it starts
to make Joel feel all these feelings
about his daughter, about Ellie, like it
all comes swelling up in him.
And finally that dam bursts Later
in the episode at night when he starts
talking to him about it,
making Joel feel all the feelings
that he doesn't want to feel.
He has another panic attack, boys
leaving Tommy, he also sees a girl
that looks just like his daughter,
who has a daughter of her own
that also looks fairly similar.
The scene of Ellie in the room
with the pop culture.
The notes from the former girl who grew up
here are also from the game,
but it happened
in a slightly different place.
She's just confused by it scorns a little
because it's all about the boys
that the girl liked, all these casual
things that seem so trivial to her
having grown up in the apocalypse,
where every day you're basically
just trying to survive to the next one.
The sign on the mantle
is meant to be a memorial to Maria's
son, Kevin, and Joel's daughter, Sarah,
who Ellie learns about for the first time.
Turns out they died
within a couple of days of each other,
even though in 2003,
Maria was living in Nebraska.
This scene of her with Maria,
where she starts defending Joel,
wasn't from the games,
but it's meant to stand at that moment.
Later, where Joel and Ellie are arguing
before they have a sort of reaffirmation
of their relationship.
At this point here,
he doesn't totally think of him
as her father yet
or anything that's significant,
but it's an example of how much closer
she feels to him.
In the interesting new bit of information
here, the way Maria tells it
is that it wasn't Joel following
Tommy with the Hunter to keep him safe.
It was actually Tommy following Joel
to keep him safe.
Maybe it's a matter of perspective,
but it's just meant to show you
what happened to Joel
after the death of his daughter.
Like it broke him her line
that the only ones who can betray us
are the ones we trust is also meant
to be foreshadowing for a huge moment.
At the end of the season.
We can wait
a few more weeks to talk about that,
but they will wind up paying that off.
The movie that they wind up watching
is The Goodbye Girl with Richard Dreyfus.
The plot of that is meant to mirror
Ellie and Joel's relationship.
It's about a woman and her daughter
who get dumped by her boyfriend
and have to move in
with a struggling actor.
Richard Dreyfuss is character in.
They eventually start
to feel like a family.
In the series,
Ellie is forced to go with Joel,
and eventually
they start to feel like a family like kin.
The title of the episode.
Then when Tommy goes to talk to Joel,
he completely breaks down and starts
crying, confessing everything that he's
been holding it like the dam burst
and it's a long, dark
night of the soul for him.
Probably the best performance that Pedro
Pascal has given on the series so far.
He should be nominated
for an Emmy for this.
He confesses everything,
all their secrets.
What's going on with Ellie?
Their mission, her immunity.
And he can't stand to let someone else
down the way that he thinks.
He let his daughter down in, test, down.
He even mentions Henry and Sam
from last week's episode,
then him trying to explain things
to Ellie.
Them arguing about their relationship
is also right out of the games,
but just happened
in a slightly different area.
I'm sorry about your daughter Joel.
Everybody I have cared for
has either died or left me.
I'm sorry about your daughter, Joel,
but I have lost people to.
You have no idea what loss is.
Everyone I have cared for
has either died or left me.
She revealed
she heard Joel's conversation with Tommy
about taking the responsibility from him
and feels betrayed by him.
She doesn't totally understand
what's going on inside his head.
She just assumes it's
because he doesn't care about her anymore.
Really, It's the fear of failing
someone that hard again.
That's keeping him from doing it
while he's thinking about things.
He also has another flashback
to his daughter.
Then by the next day when they come back
together, their relationship is much,
much stronger than it was before.
Love the actual scene of them
getting back together the next morning
to like water under the bridge.
She doesn't even hesitate
when he asked her to choose.
All right, let's go. Peace.
We're out of here.
But when Tommy does ask him to return
after he's done with his mission,
in his mind, Joel does plan to return
and continue living here.
As they ride away, they play a slower
version of The Last of Us theme music.
Joel teaches Ellie to fire the rifle,
paying off all of her requests
from earlier.
And he's smiling
like they share a moment together.
Joel starts telling Ellie
more about his past before the fungus,
when he and Tommy worked as housing
contractors,
opening up more about his past
just in general.
Five days later,
they arrive at the university.
In the way that this plays out
is pretty accurate to the game.
When Joel tells Ellie
that he's changed his mind
about what he wants to do in the future
and he thinks he like to sing,
he does play guitar and sing in the games.
Her reaction to the monkeys
is also right out of the game.
Those monkeys must be from the old labs.
Look at them go,
Oh, those monkeys.
Yeah, Almost them.
They wind up finding a sign
from the fireflies
that they've retreated to Salt Lake City,
Utah, and St Mary's Hospital.
So that's like their next goal.
They're heading to, obviously
a bit of a detour
while Joel is trying to recover,
but they're eventually headed
to Salt Lake City.
The band of Raiders here
are just meant to be one of the random
roving bands
that Maria and Tommy spoke of.
Joel's injured badly and dying,
and they're too far away to get back
safely to Tommy's.
So Ellie is forced now to protect Joel
while he recovers during the winter.
Now you see why it's so important
that she learn basic survival skills
and how to shoot the rifle
and do some basic hunting.
Gonna come in real handy real soon.
Even though they make you wonder
he is alive.
He's just on the edge of death.
So she's going to.
To drag him to one of these
shacks for shelter while he recovers.
In the song that plays over the credits
is a cover of Never Let Me Down Again
by Depeche Mode, which thematically
is all about their relationship.
Joel Not letting L.A. down,
but now very important.
Ellie Not letting Joel down and making
sure that he survives his wound.
Overall, it was a great episode.
If you spotted any Easter eggs
or references
that I didn't mention in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My Last of Us Episode 7 Trailer Video.
We'll post Monday in my full Episode
7 video We'll post next week
when they release it all the rest of the
episodes are back on the normal schedule.
Everyone click here for my full Breakdown
and Easter Eggs for Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania
and click here for that last of us.
Episode seven Video
Update the link as soon as I posted.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.